democrats getting a wake-up call on the
midterms as liberals take biden's us
versus them narrative to the next level
while the media acts as if dems have the
momentum going into november a new york
times polling guru is bursting their
bubble claiming the warning signs are
flashing again and that recent strong
poll numbers may be a mirage equating
them to 2020 polling misses that
overstated support for now president joe
biden meanwhile the biden administration
is continuing their attacks on extremist
republicans
democrats the stakes are so high
as the president as our president made
clear in philadelphia last week
the threats we face as a nation are
great
threats to our freedom
threats to our very democracy
and we need to speak about that
and so today
we all by coming together
reaffirmed
that we
refuse to let extremist
so-called leaders
dismantle our democracy
coming together except for those
extremists liberals taking biden's q and
smearing trump voters on september 11th
with some guy named dean tweeting
terrorists or terrorists be they bin
laden's al-qaeda or trump's maga
time to hold trump accountable
biden's dhs secretary is echoing that
sentiment while at ground zero
the threat landscape has evolved
considerably over the last 20 years we
are seeing an emerging threat of course
over the last several years of the
domestic violent extremists an ideology
of hate anti-government sentiment false
narratives propagated on online
platforms even personal grievances
you know uh dana i had a i was going to
talk about the polling but i didn't even
see that yeah
that is a government official basically
taking a crap on 9 11. he basically he
basically marginalized
the memories of those people by equating
it to some kind of political agenda it's
absolutely disgusting he did it there on
at ground zero and it wasn't even if he
was asked about it he wanted to make
that point and so he said then let me
add what the the concern is on he went
to domestic terrorists and that's what i
think you'll see all of the democrats do
like kamala harris did it yesterday on
meet the press as well so you have all
of that happening in the meantime you've
got terrorists the actual terrorists uh
they don't they're not on our timeline
yeah they're super patient right they
vow to destroy us and they regroup but
we have done a great job i think as a
country in a bipartisan way supporting
the military and our intelligence
officials in order to keep al-qaeda on
its back foot that is a bipartisan
achievement it's something that we can
all agree on if i were majors i would
have said even if the white house had
said we need you to make this point i've
said not today
the last point i would make is yesterday
at the end of the
u.s open in which a norwegian was
playing a spaniard at the end they both
get to make comments what's the first
thing that caspar rude and carlos
alcarez talked about this solemn day
this important day this emotional day
and thank you for letting me share it
with you i have you in my thoughts and
prayers i'm sorry for what happened to
you like that was their instinct and
then you have somebody like this
the homeland security secretary
at ground zero saying that which was um
it's beyond disappointing but also not
as surprising yeah you know judge
department of homeland security there
are there's a hundred thousand people
dying from uh overdoses drugs coming
across the border one could easily point
right back at him
and go you
you know what's you could equate to 911
your lack
of an ability to prevent this death how
dare he point at january 6 when he's in
charge of something that is killing
people
because they have an agenda and an
ideology that is not connected to
reality what they're concerned about is
winning and winning at all costs the
fact that yesterday a 911 was such a
significant day in our history when 3
000 americans died the horror inflicted
on upon so many families who suffer from
it and continue to suffer from it every
day is of no concern to them their
concern is about winning and this whole
idea of you know we're not really
worried about any of that stuff we're
worried about domestic terrorism and
domestic terrorism is all about those
maga republicans those other people the
other people that we have to get rid of
and i went back greg a few months ago
when i remember jim jordan talked about
multiple whistleblowers who had gone to
congress and talked about the fact that
fbi officials were pressuring agents to
field agents to categorize domestic
violence extremism
uh
as as even though these cases didn't
meet the criteria of domestic violence
extremism this is a plotted uh agenda
that they have and they will pursue it
every day until the election
you know harold uh who would you rather
be in this situation not like just
forget the democrats or republicans but
comparing their situations
who do you like if you had to bet which
situation would you prefer to be in come
november like who looks like who really
has the momentum here well first off
happy birthday oh why thank you and
and thank you for the card i didn't
expect cash
but you know what i can spend on
anything i want and i don't have to
return that shirt that jesse didn't buy
me the um
look i think when when politicians try
to politicize uh this day it's a bad
yesterday is a bad day i remember where
we all were last year we were at mets
stadium
and
uh the u.s open final was that day also
we happened to be at the baseball game
and how
great it was to be on that set with with
so many including uh the tunnels the
tower founder who reminded us all and
jesse who you read like an eight-minute
thing saying the million dollars that
fox had given on behalf of fox had given
on behalf of trying to build homes so
you want to be on the side of america
that day on the side of americans
and we're in an election season but i
hope politicians are able to put that
aside part of part of what we talked
about the early part of this was the
polling and whether or not this polling
stuff is is wrong look polling in the
past few election cycles has become
less of a science and more like science
fiction in some ways in the way that the
way that some of these things have come
about i think it's important for the
polling industry for their own
credibility sake to maybe come forward
and be more transparent about how they
do these things but look you asked me a
basic question i'd rather be on the side
all the time of america and politicians
who want to politicize that day
wrong day to do it whatever party you're
in gotcha so uh jesse birthday why thank
you why thank you yeah it's tough when
you turn the big 40.
you know but um
jesse is it
should we just admit that maybe this is
working on the democrats strategy
to use january 6 as a political uh
weapon is actually might be paying off
it is paying off they're raiding they're
stealing people's phones they're
probably listening to my personal
conversations
and i know that they're listening so i'm
trying to throw them off a little bit
but it's really dangerous because you
have the media and the fbi and probably
the cia all on the same side they're
using all the bush war on terror tactics
against
not al qaeda or isis they're using it
against mega republicans do you remember
i don't know during the bush years they
say oh
democrats stop politicizing 9 11. if you
were a republican and you were a flag
pin they said you were politicizing 9
11. now they get up on 9 11 and call
half the country terrorists how is that
not politicizing 9 11. january 6 is
their 9 11. it's what they've been
waiting for it was the only war they
actually wanted to fight they didn't
want to fight the cold war they were
awol didn't really want to fight the war
on terror remember all the top democrat
lawyers wanted to go represent al qaeda
remember they flew down to gitmo that
they did pro bono how about chuck todd
totally in on this war game the question
uh we are now facing a threat from
within
is the threat equal or greater than the
threat we face on 9 11 what kind of
question is that chuck that's like are
the republicans racist pedophiles or are
they worse than racist pedophiles also i
remember the war on terror you remember
how the democrats were so upset about
the muslims oh islamophobia that is the
worst islamophobia is actually worse
than radical islam and they would always
say the same thing
not all muslims are terrorists what do
they say today all republicans are
terrorists
they give them more of a benefit the
doubt also
you see now they're saying if you
believe the election
was unfair that makes you a threat to
democracy well if you look at the
polling more democrats think the 2016
election was rigged then republicans
think the 2020 election was rigged they
say oh if you have a personal grievance
that makes you a radical
i don't know about you i have a lot of
personal grievances i hope they don't
put me on a terror watch list yeah
that's a good point all right boy that's
very unsettling the whole thing it's
your birthday relax i know i'm trying to
i'm gonna eat a steak
i'm thinking about it now all right
coming up a democrat mug by reality
california liberal wants harsher rules
for your guns but you can't even keep
hers from getting stolen hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now